...
strada
Ragazzi, che ansia! Non vi rendete mica conto voi, cosa vuol dire essere qua?
Comunque, allora lo sapete, noi questa sera racconteremo la prima di tre ben tre
rivolte popolari del Medioevo che io mi sono proposto di raccontarvi in queste tre serate.
Vi racconto tre rivolte popolari del Medioevo perché il tema di quest'anno del Festival
della Mente è il futuro e centra il futuro. Prevedere il futuro è sempre stata
un'ossessione dell'umanità naturalmente. In altre epoche cercavano di prevedere il
futuro con sistemi che a loro sembravano razionali, osservando le stelle oppure interrogando i morti,
la negromanzia. Anche noi interroghiamo il futuro con sistemi che a noi sembrano
razionali, chiediamo agli economisti come sarà il pill dell'anno prossimo. Ed è esattamente
la stessa cosa ovviamente, risponde solo a una nostra ansia. Dopodiché un conto è interrogare
il futuro e un conto è dirsi, ecco ci sono nella storia umana dei momenti in cui molta
gente si dice, insomma il futuro sarà uguale al presente, non mi piace. Vogliamo provare a
cambiarlo questo futuro. Le rivolte, le rivolte popolari che scandiscono tutta la storia umana
sono sempre dei momenti in cui un'infinità di gente decide che il futuro, così come lo vede,
non gli piace e prova a cambiarlo. Poi di solito se noi le conosciamo come rivolte, vuol dire che
non ci sono riusciti a cambiarlo. Perché quando riescono a cambiarlo invece le chiamiamo
rivoluzioni e allora davvero il mondo va a cambia l'aria e il futuro cambia. Quando invece le
chiamiamo rivolte, sommosse, tumulti, allora vuol dire che poi alla fine non ce l'hanno fatta,
però loro credevano lo stesso di cambiare il mondo e questo è quello che succede molte volte nel
corso del Medioevo e la prima che raccontiamo stasera è la rivolta dei contadini francesi passata
alla storia come la Jacquerie che durò qualche settimana, non di più, nell'estate del 1358.
Prima cosa da segnalare, le rivolte che racconte, adesso non so chi di voi riuscirà a esserci
tre sere consecutive e uscirà da qui avendo una conoscenza dettagliatissima delle rivolte
popolari nel Medioevo, ma una cosa che accomuna queste rivolte che io vi racconto e che sono tutte
brevi, durano poche settimane, poi vengono represse, ma in quelle poche settimane succedono cose tali
che rimangono per sempre incise nella memoria collettiva, durano pochissimo e arrivano completamente
inaspettate. La rivolta dei contadini francesi nell'estate del 1358 arriva senza che nessuno
si immaginasse che poteva succedere una cosa del genere e anche come è cominciata questa cosa,
nessuno lo capisce espera bene perché è una rivolta che non ci ha messo niente a dilagare in
tutta la Francia del Nord e poi i cronistiche la raccontano se io sono qua che vi parlo per un'ora di
queste cose perché molta gente all'epoca dopo quando tutto è finito si sono seduti a tavolino e hanno
scritto io ho visto succedere questo o mi hanno raccontato che è successo per anni i cronisti
arrivati a quell'anno e in quell'anno è successo questo che cosa è successo come è cominciato noi non lo
sappiamo se c'è stato un singolo episodio se uno se lo sapesse potrebbe dire è in quel
tale villaggio quel tale giorno che è cominciato tutto noi non lo sappiamo di sicuro però quello che sappiamo
che queste cose si espandono rapidamente anche se c'è stato un singolo episodio iniziale di questa
rivolta poi poi ha innescatto un contagio fulmineo noi potremmo immaginare che nel medioevo le notizie ci
mettessero tanto tempo ad arrivare sì rispetto a noi tanto tempo però un uomo a piedi fa 30
chilometri tranquillamente in un giorno e se porta una notizia incredibile ne fa anche 50
chilometri un uomo a piedi non ci mette molto capite la notizia per attraversare un paese specialmente
quando appunto che notizia i contadini hanno cominciato a ammazzare i signori poi appunto
qualche cronista ha l'idea dell'episodio iniziale alcuna un po di gente dei villaggi della campagna
si riunirono nei loro villaggi dappertutto senza capi dobbiamo stare attenti quando
nessuno scrive a caso ogni parola ha un peso quando un cronista ti dice che questi si sono
radunati all'improvviso senza capi cosa vuol dire vuol dire un pregiudizio molto chiaro non
è una cosa organizzata non sanno cosa stanno facendo quando sai cosa stai facendo hai anche
dei capi hai un programma dire che questi si riuniscono senza capi è come dire che è una cosa
che è successa neanche loro lo sapevano cosa stavano facendo pregiudizio dei cronisti dell'epoca
che sono praticamente tutti ostili i cronisti appartengono alla classe dirigente quelli che
sanno leggere scrivere hanno tempo di scrivere libri e classe dirigente per loro la rivolta è
stata una cosa inspiegabile e orrenda meno male che alla fine li hanno ammazzati tutti ecco dopo
di che quindi è chiaro una roba inspiegabile assurda senza capi e non erano neanche 100 all'inizio
ed dissero che i nobili e i cavalieri svergoniavano e rovinavano il regno e che sarebbe stata una
buona cosa distruggerli tutti tutti dissero ha ragione ha ragione alla malora chi non ci
sta e dunque la gente dei villaggi cominciò ad attaccare le case dei nobili dei cavalieri
siamo in campagna siamo in Francia il regno di Francia nel 300 è un grande prospero regno il
più grande regno d'Europa il più popoloso ma è campagna non è come l'Italia l'Italia della
stessa epoca ne parleremo domani con chi di voi ci sarà la rivolta dei chompi a Firenze l'Italia
è un mondo di città di mercanti di industria di soldi che girano la Francia pure essendo un
regno potentissimo è quasi tutta campagna c'è un'unica vera città parigi ne parleremo
tante piccole cittadine ma il regno di Francia è campagna una marea di contadini è una piccola
percentuale di nobili i nobili sono l'1 per cento il 2 per cento della popolazione da una
regione all'altra può cambiare un po' una piccola minoranza e la massa sono contadini i
contadini sono quelli che lavorano che producono che pagano l'affitto e che pagano le tasse i
nobili vivono senza lavorare non pagano niente ben intenso non dobbiamo immaginare dice siccome
siamo nel medioevo i servi della gleba niente del genere non ci sono servi praticamente nella
Francia del 300 è una società prospera girano soldi un contadino può anche essere un contadino
ricco però un contadino lavora e paga i nobili non pagano non pagano l'affitto perché la terra è
loro mica tutta e c'è il capitalismo anche lì uno può se hai i soldi compra ci sono contadini che
si sono comprati il loro pezzo di terra ma la maggior parte della terra e dei nobili e che
quindi incassano gli affitti e le tasse il recchie delle tasse ma i nobili non le fa pagare perché
i nobili cavalieri che sanno fare la guerra servono il re in un altro modo sono il puntello del suo
potere quindi ai nobili le tasse non si fanno pagare le paga la gente che lavora naturalmente
e non basta i nobili hanno anche il potere politico perché anche se nel regno scusate
questa lezioncina di storia medievale così in tre minuti e per capire che mondo è questo dove vivono
questi qua di cui parleremo stasera loro vivono in un mondo dove c'è il re certo è il re comando
fino a un certo punto ma in ogni villaggio c'è il signore locale in ogni villaggio c'è un castello
ogni due o tre villaggi c'è un castello il padrone del castello è il signore del posto il re gli concede
di gestire il potere su quei due o tre paesini di riscuotere delle imposte di mantenere lo e il
signore è quello che arresta i malfattori che impicca i briganti che se tu hai un alite vai da
lui non c'è un giudice del re vai dal signore e lui multa e ordina decide comanda e poi mille
piccoli obblighi di pagamenti di tutti i tipi vendi un pezzo di terra anche oggi se vendi un pezzo
di terra un alloggio paghi una tassa ma la paghi allo stato all'epoca la paghi al signore in altre
parole il potere pubblico che mantiene l'ordine e a cui tu continuamente devi pagare non è una
entità astratta è il signore del posto uno che conosci da quando sei nato e tu dipendi da lui
e contro questa classe di signori di nobili che sanno fare la guerra e la fanno bene anche o meno
bene ne parleremo subito ma insomma la sanno fare o dovrebbero saperla fare la guerra e per il resto
non lavorano e incassano sono i padroni sono i signori sono quelli che comandano la massa dei
contadini che ripeto contiene anche un sacco di gente che i soldi li ha fatti però non ne può
più a un certo punto di questo sistema farei un ultimo commento sul brano brevissimo che vi ho
letto prima ricordate cosa dice il cronista ed dissero che i nobili e i cavalieri svergoniavano e
rovinavano il regno allora i protagonisti di questa rivolta sono contadini che vivono in
villaggi che magari non sono mai andati più lontano del mercato più vicino ma siamo in Francia
ognuno di loro sa che noi siamo nel regno di Francia e il re rappresenta tutti noi il regno è un
potere pubblico rappresenta una collettività vi sottolineo questo perché domani parleremo
della Firenze della stessa epoca nell'Italia di quell'epoca non c'è niente del genere non c'è
il regno nell'Italia di quell'epoca ognuno è cittadino di Sarzana ed è cittadino di Sarzana
e guarda male quelli di Spezia dopo di che la patria è la tua città e se sei un contadino
neanche quello perché la città comanda anche in campagna se sei un contadino paghi e obbedisci
al comune cittadino più vicino mentre invece in Francia tutti sanno che noi comunque viviamo
nel regno di Francia e la rivolta vuol dire che i contadini decidono che i nobili non stanno più
facendo la loro parte perché questa è una comunità ognuno ha il suo dovere da compiere e noi che
siamo la maggioranza quelli che lavorano e pagano decidiamo che non ci va più bene come viene
gestito questo nostro regno di Francia dicevo il primo episodio qualche cronista appunto
sa quale è stato precisamente il primo episodio di violenza e aggredirono diversi gentiluomini
che si trovavano nel villaggio di Saint-Louis e ne uccisero nove e fatto questo ogni giorno crescevano
in numero altri cronisti raccontano una storia diversa si mossero senza altre armi che bastoni
ferrati e coltelli andarono alla casa di un cavaliere sfondarono la porta e lo uccisero con
sua moglie e i figli e poi bruciarono la casa poi andarono a un castello e fecero peggio perché
presero il cavaliere e lo legarono molto stretto a un palo e violarono davanti ai suoi occhi la
dama e la figlia poi uccisero la dama incinta e la figlia e poi il cavaliere e tutti i bambini
e bruciarono il castello quale che sia stato l'episodio iniziale l'insurrezione di l'aga in
pochi giorni in tutta la Francia del nord a nord di parigi tra la piccardia e la normandia
fra bovè e ruon e i cronisti descrivono una campagna dove la gente infolla abbandona i suoi
villaggi e si uniscono a questa massa di gente che va migliaia ormai che va da un villaggio
all'altro con un'idea fissa in testa andiamo a cercare i nobili e li ammazziamo perché non hanno
più diritto di vivere in questo regno e se dio non avesse posto rimedio il male si sarebbe tanto
moltiplicato che le comunità avrebbero distrutto tutti i nobili e la santa chiesa e tutti i ricchi
in tutti i paesi questo ovviamente è un cronista che scrive dopo sospiro di sollievo sappiamo che
finita pensa se avessero vinto loro ecco allora sì sarebbe stato il mondo alla rovescia tutti i
signori distrutti ma anche qui una parola su cui volevo attirare la vostra attenzione cosa ha detto
il cronista le comunità avrebbero distrutto tutti i nobili comunità è un'altra parola chiave
anche a livello dei contadini e dei poveri questa non è una società informe questa è una società
organizzata tu abiti in un villaggio non importa quanto sei povero se sei un abitante di quel
villaggio fai parte di una collettività di una comunità che elege il suo sindaco il suo
consiglio comunale che ha dei beni comuni da gestire e ogni anno si litica perché il sindaco
vuole affittarli a buon prezzo ai suoi amici invece i poveri del villaggio li vogliono usare
loro per dare da mangiare alla loro vacca e quindi si litiga e si fa politica c'è la parrocchia
il parrocco c'è la confraternita dove gli abitanti del paese laici però gestiscono delle
attività religiosa in concorrenza con la parrocchia in altre parole tutti vivono in una
comunità dove si fa politica tutti i giorni e sono le comunità che si ribellano ai signori
non i poveri neanche i contadini perché al paese c'è anche il fabbro ferraio il maniscalco il
negoziante l'artigiano il parrocco e tutti fanno parte della comunità ed è tutto questo mondo
della gente che lavora e paga che si ribella e in cui vicito sempre brani dai cronisti e in
queste assemblee c'erano per lo più contadini ma c'erano anche dei ricchi borgesi e altri e tutti
i gentiluomini che potevano prendere li uccidevano un altro cronista fa un'osservazione ribellatrice
dice mammano che si è sparsa la notizia di quello che succedeva anche la dove i rivoltosi non
erano ancora arrivati i nobili per un po di tempo si erano ritirati e non si vedevano più andare
in giro come prima e questo è molto rivelatore perché la gente odia il nobile perché il nobile
va in giro a cavallo guarda gli altri dall'alto in basso tu sei uno che lavora sei un pezzente
un villano dice adesso i nobili non per un po non sono più andati in giro come prima e ancora
attraversavano la patria con le loro armi e seguendo le bandiere e questa è una cosa di nuovo se
uno conosce quel mondo non solo le armi bene le armi d'accordo quello che hanno il falcetto
la scure il bastone ma le bandiere le bandiere vuol dire moltissimo noi oggi non ce lo immaginiamo
neanche cosa possono voler dire le bandiere prima cosa le bandiere vogliono dire che sono organizzati
militarmente perché le forze militari medievali sono tutte incentrate sulla bandiera in che senso
mi spiego hai un esercito di mille cavalieri va bene ma ognuno di quei cavalieri è al seguito
di un signore e ogni signore ha i suoi dieci quindici venti cavalieri e ha la sua bandiera
col suo stemma perché poi quando va in battaglia e sei lì dentro nel polverone dopo un po non
capisci più niente non ne puoi più magari tor esco un momento perché nelle battaglie medievali
uno può uscire un momento di solito ma dove vado dove è la nostra bandiera lì lì c'è il
mio capo lì ci sono i miei amici io vado lì sto lì e quando i comuni si organizzano e anche
la gente a piedi gli artigiani cominciano a fare la guerra e ci vogliono le bandiere quando l'esercito
di firenze o di siena va a fare la guerra escono tutti quelli di quel rione di quel quartiere di
quella strada tutti insieme con la loro bandiera perché poi appunto in battaglia quando si mette
male dove è la bandiera ci si stringe lì tanto è vero che in battaglia è importantissimo prendere
le bandiere dell'avversario buttarle giù perché quando quelli non vedono più la loro
bandiera non è che stai lì ad aspettare quindi prima cosa hanno le bandiere vuol dire che questi
contadini hanno capito da subito che devono organizzarsi militarmente ma poi c'è anche un
altra cosa che tutte queste bandiere sono il simbolo di un potere legittimo tu sei un cavaliere
al seguito di un signore quel signore governa quelle terre e la sua bandiera è il simbolo del suo
potere se sei al seguito del re c'è la bandiera del re se sei in francia coi gilni di francia e
se sei un rione di firenze hai la bandiera del tuo rione o della tua corporazione vuol dire vuol dire
che se tu stai seguendo la bandiera stai facendo una cosa legittima sei al tuo posto con un
autorità legittima che autorizza quello che stai facendo e quindi questa gente ha la convinzione
che quello che sta facendo è legittimo i nobili sono i traditori e noi siamo quelli che fanno
giustizia i cronisti sottolineano con stupore anche un'altra cosa dice e uccidevano tutti i
nobili che riuscivano a trovare anche i loro propri signori fatto che il cronista si stupisca ci
deve far riflettere capite cosa vuol dire tu sei un contadino non ne puoi più dei nobili vedi
un nobile e dice dai tiriamolo giù da cavallo e ammazziamolo ma è un nobile qualunque ma il
tuo signore quello che tu sei abituato tutta la vita che lui è il signore del tuo paese
l'autorità legittima del tuo paese è a lui che obbedisci paghi e non solo lo conosci da sempre
questa è una società di antropologi dicono faccia a faccia è una società dove tutti si
conoscono e non risparmiavano neanche quelli con cui erano stati allevati ed educati dolcemente
certo perché certo fra il contadino e il signore del villaggio c'è una bella differenza ma da
bambini giocavano insieme e vanno a messa nella stessa chiesa la stessa messa è diverso ammazzare
anche il tuo signore piuttosto che non dire in generale ammazziamo i nobili quello sono buoni
tutti ma ammazzare il tuo signore che conosci da sempre è un'altra cosa a questo punto i
cronisti che raccontano quello che succede hanno una scelta andare avanti o fermarsi descrivendo
particolari atrocità alcuni cronisti decidono di descrivere delle atrocità non oserei scrivere
le orribili cose che facevano alle dame ma fra le altre cose disoneste uccisero un cavaliere e lo
misero allo spiedo e lo arrostirono sotto gli occhi della dama e dei bambini dopo che dieci o
dodici ebbero violentato la dama vollerò fargliene mangiare per forza poi la fecerò morire di
mala morte e fra i prigionieri quando poi dopo repressa la rivolta cominciano i processi dice
fra tra quelli che venivano processati c'era chi confessava di aver aiutato a violentare chi
sei dame chi 8 9 10 12 e le avevano uccise incinte parentesi un mondo che abbiamo perduto che
non è più il nostro le donne sono sempre incinte le donne esposate o hanno il neonato sono incinte
perché si fanno la coppia fa bambini continuamente continuamente perché è un dovere perché è così
l'umanità deve a moltiplicarsi sta scritto e poi noi vogliamo la famiglia deve moltiplicarsi
e i bambini muoiono come niente e quindi ne deve fare tanti quindi se noi ci immaginiamo la gente
in una via di un villaggio medievale dobbiamo immaginarci che è pieno di bambini piccoli uno
sciame dappertutto ed è pieno di donne incinte ma non era su questo che volevo fermarmi nel
discorso delle atrocità il discorso delle atrocità pone un problema ovviamente a noi che sulla base
di questi racconti cerchiamo di dirvi cosa è successo davvero ci dobbiamo credere allora da
un lato ovviamente la storia del 900 ci insegna che non c'è atrocità che non possa verificarsi e
anzi si sono verificate cose che nessuno avrebbe mai immaginato però al tempo stesso non vi sembri
una contraddizione non bisogna credere ciecamente quando un cronista o un giornalista ostile racconta
le orribili cose che fanno quelli là perché anche qui la storia ci insegna che invece molte volte
le atrocità vengono amplificate c'è un esempio c'è le berrimo e garantito qui divago un po mi
scusate ci ho pensato a lungo se fare questa parentesi alla fine ho detto va bene chi se frega
la faccio scoppio della prima guerra mondiale 1914 i tedeschi invadono il belgio e la francia del
nord i tedeschi invadono il belgio e la francia del nord commettendo atrocità nel senso che
continuamente fusilano civili e bruciano villaggi lo fanno perché le truppe tedesche hanno un
terrore fanatico dei partigiani dei franchi tiratori come dicono loro li hanno insegnato a
stare ben attenti perché quelli sono paesi infidi i civili ti sparano dalle finestre tutti
loro sono convinti di questo e quindi un esercito di milioni di uomini che attraverso un paese nemico
nel panico nel terrore che ti sparano addosso dalle finestre a quel punto succede che ti convinci
che ti hanno sparato e quando un capitano che comando una compagnia in un villaggio si convince che
da una finestra gli hanno sparato non ci mette niente a dire portate il sindaco il parroco
li fuciliamo sul posto ediamo fuoco al villaggio quindi i tedeschi attraversano il belgio e la
francia del nord nel 1914 commettendo atrocità che per l'epoca sono inimmaginabili fusilano e
bruciano ma i giornali inglesi e francesi cominciano a raccontare che i tedeschi tagliano le mani ai
bambini e cavano gli occhi ai bambini e sventrano le donne incinte e se catturano in fermiera le
strappano gli occhi tutte queste cose sono scritte su tutti i quotidiani inglesi e francesi dell'epoca
tutto il mondo ci crede dopo di che si scopra che non c'è assolutamente niente di vero a questo
punto noi siamo attrezzati per sapere che non importa quale atrocità uno commette davvero chi
vuole descriverti sotto una certa luce se ne inventerà delle altre pornografiche se possibile
ancora più atroci per l'appunto fino a quel torno alla mia rivolta francese fino a quel cronista
inglese che inglese scrive da un altro paese scrive quello che gli hanno raccontato scrive
parecchi anni dopo e quello meno informato di tutti guarda caso lui conosce le atrocità peggiori
dice i ribelli si erano nominati un capo che si chiamava jack bonhomme e questo jack bonhomme
in molti luoghi strappò i bambini dai ventri delle loro madri e per rinfrescarsi si ungeva il corpo
con il sangue di quei bambini allora qui uno si sente di dire no non ci credo mi dispiace non
è successo anche perché me lo racconti solo tu che non c'eri e scrivi 50 anni dopo fammi il
piacere dai però il meccanismo è chiaro questa rivolta ha societato un tale terrore un tale
orrore che non c'è niente di così abbominevole che non si possa attribuire a questi rivoltosi
avete sentito il cronista dice avevano un capo che si chiamava jack bonhomme questa rivolta si
chiama la jack ri la chiamiamo così noi me la chiamano già così i contemporanei perché si chiama
così qualcuno appunto crede che i ribelli avessero un capo che si chiamava così questa cattiva
gente aveva un capitano che chiamavano jack bonhomme e avevano fatto un re fra loro che
chiamavano jack bonhomme jack bonhomme non è mai esistito come singolo personaggio però però si
dice no è che jack bonhomme era un soprannome era un soprannome spregiativo che si dava i
contadini lo dice anche un cronista a quelle epoca i nobili facendosi beffe degli uomini
rozi e semplici li chiamavano jack bonhomme io devo dire che mi stupisco un po perché il cronista è
un contemporaneo cosa vuol dire a quel tempo se stai scrivendo in quell'epoca alla gente che
c'era e senti il bisogno di spiegare non so a me non mi torna tanto io sono arrivato a pensare
che probabilmente jack bonhomme era tutt'al più una specie di maschera come chi dicesse non
solo zio sam che personifica agli americani pulcinella che può personificare no ecco è
gianduglia se volete allora jack bonhomme magari personificava i contadini ma nessuno aveva
mai chiamato jack i contadini in genere invece e questa è una cosa importante o meglio che a
me sembra interessante anche se non me la spiego bene quando scoppia la rivolta si sente il bisogno
di dare un nome a questi rivoltosi e gli si appiccica questo soprannome di jack e questa è una cosa
che accommuna quasi tutte le rivolte nel medioevo e anche nell'età moderna si arriva fino alla
rivoluzione francese i sanculotti a me piacerebbe sapere se sanculotti si diceva davvero già prima
o se invece e quando questi prendono il potere che cominciano a chiamarli sanculotti quelli che
portano i calzoni non portano i calzoni corti dei nobili le rivolte nel medioevo nell'età moderna
quasi sempre si inventano un nome per i ribelli è una cosa misteriosa perché non si capisceasoni
chi è che se lo inventa chi è che glielo da e c'è qualcosa di molto profondo evidentemente nel
fatto di aver bisogno di avere un nome che vuol dire che tu sei di quelli lì ecco sei uno di quelli
gli giac se lo danno da soli questo nome qualche cronista dice così questa gente che si dicono
gli giac gli giac come dicevano loro oppure di non danno gli altri questo nome i villani che a
partire da quel momento furono chiamati giac queste comunità che la gente chiamava giac bonhomme
la compagnia degli giac è una terminologia che arriva anche nel linguaggio ufficiale nel
linguaggio dei documenti prodotti dallo stato e qui mi fermo un attimo perché vi devo raccontare un
altro pezzettino di come funzionava quel mondo faccio un piccolo salto in avanti l'abbiamo
detto la rivolta verrà repressa verrà repressa nel sangue ma a un certo momento una caratteristica
della giustizia nel medioevo e che dopo che hai impazzato però poi ci si ferma e si dà un bel colpo
di spugna ed è tutto finito perché l'autorità suprema l'autorità del re si caratterizza per il
fatto che fa giustizia spietatamente se ce ne bisogno ma anche per il fatto che può graziare la
grazia sopravvivere anche oggi no prerogativa del presidente della repubblica ma oggi è un fossile
serve politicamente in certi casi ma non conta nella realtà concreta quotidiana la grazia
in passato contava enormemente per un re sapere che io sono quello che ti può condannare a
morte era importante ma era altrettanto importante far sapere che io sono quello che ti può graziare
la grazia era importante almeno quanto la giustizia e chi ha la mia età si ricorderà che fino a un
po di tempo fa il ministero come si chiamava il ministero ministero di grazia e giustizia con
la grazia che viene prima e allora nel medioevo quello che noi vediamo succedere che la giustizia
è feroce uccide in pic poi a un certo punto comincia a pubblicare delle lettere in cui dice il tal
dei tali ha fatto delle cose tremende spaventose ma noi abbiamo deciso di graziarlo di solito
dietro c'è una storia di bustarelle agli uscieri agli avvocati ma è comunque tutto accettato il
re grazia e dunque dopo la rivolta della giacchieri noi abbiamo una valanga di lettere di remissione
concesse dal re che dicono appunto il tal dei tali sto parlando di questo per direvi che il termine
giac è entrato anche nel linguaggio ufficiale no il tal dei tali che all'epoca stava con gli
giac il tal altro che stava dalla parte degli giac di quelli che allora si chiamavano gli
giac bonhom il tal dei tali che ha fatto ucciso si è detto c'è una ma noi lo perdoniamo e può
tornare libero a casa sua e non succede niente quindi gli giac e quindi la giacchieri e qualche
cronista lo dice quella giacchieri gli giacchi villani a partire da quel momento il termine
uscirà dall'uso e nessuno mai più dirà gli giac per dire i contadini lo si dice in quel momento
gli giac sono quelli che attraversavano il paese in folla e ammazzavano i nobili e la folla attraversa
la francia del nord e la gente li aspetta gli giac sono arrivati là domani gli giac saranno qui
i nobili scappano e gli giac attraversano villaggi e città applauditi dalla folla che li accoglie
con entusiasmo gli giac vennero a gai fontene la contesta di valua che era là ebbe paura e gli
mostrò buon viso e gli fece dare dei viveri perché avevano l'abitudine nei paesi e città in cui
passavano che la gente uomini e donne metteva i tavoli in strada e la mangiavano i giac e poi
passavano oltre bruciando le case dei genti luomini come una specie di pellegrinaggio no il
medievo sono abituati alle masse che all'improvviso si mettono in movimento per andare in pelle
grinaggio questo è un pellegrinaggio un po speciale però dove passano sono i benvenuti
tavoli e da mangiare da bere per tutti ci sono gli aspetti carnevaleschi che accompagnano sempre
le rivolte la gente prima di bruciare la casa del nobile ci entra qualcuno ruva saccheggia cosa
porti via i vestiti portavano via la roba e rivestivano se stessi e le loro donne contadine in modo
più pittoresco è chiaro se ce l'hai con il nobile anche per quello lui va vestito tutto
colorato gli abiti colorati sono cari noi siamo tutti i vestiti di abiti tessuti in casa tutti
grigi ma adesso che abbiamo saccheggiato il castello anche mia moglie si pavoneggia con l'abito
colorato della contessa e hanno anche i simboli una di queste lettere di remissione in cui si
perdone un tizio il quale all'epoca in cui i plebei del bovesì si erano mossi contro i nobili
del paese lui prese e portava sul suo cappello al posto della piuma un aratro di legno e diceva
che lui stava dalla parte degli giac allora capite siamo in pieno robinù no c'è il cappello con
la piuma e lui al posto della piuma si è messo un piccolo aratro di legno e l'aratro è un carico di
significati simbolici l'aratro arare naturalmente è il principale dei lavori contadini è il più
importante dei lavori contadini è un simbolo tenete conto che il verbo che noi usiamo per il
verbo lavorare che per noi indica qualunque tipo di attività lavorativa in francese la
bourrée significa arare il campo cioè nell'inconscio collettivo dei francesi lavorare vuol dire
arare il campo quello è il lavoro ma naturalmente l'aratro è un attrezzo costoso mica tutti gli
abitanti della campagna non la rato i pezzenti non ce l'hanno quelli i braccianti che lavorano
giornata quelli non ce l'hanno mica avere l'aratro e i buoi vuol dire che sei qualcuno al villaggio di
nuovo non è la rivolta dei pezzenti è la rivolta di tutto un mondo che è convinto di poter
benissimo stare in piedi da solo anche senza i nobili a cui dover obbedire ora fin qui non
abbiamo parlato delle motivazioni immediate che li muovono han deciso che sono stufi ma perché
han deciso che sono stufi a beh qualche cronista naturalmente dice ma non lo sapevano neanche
loro cosa volevano fare poi ai processi tu chiedevi all'imputato perché sei andato rispondevano
che non sapevano tranne che le avevano visto fare agli altri e allora anche lo ecco ma qualche
cronista è più preciso i contadini venivano depredati da ogni parte e non c'era nessuno che
resistesse ai briganti e ai nemici e perciò i contadini dissero insorgiamo contro questi
nobili traditori che si sono dimenticati di difendere il regno e non pensano ad altro che a
divorare le sostanze del popolo allora cosa sta succedendo cosa c'è nell'inconscio di
questa gente nell'inconscio di questa gente c'è il quello che hanno sentito predicare in chiesa
per tutta la loro vita e cioè la società umana cari ragazzi è fatta di tante condizioni diverse
ognuno ha il suo compito dio ha dato a ognuno il suo compito e sono tutti importanti la società
funziona meravigliosamente se ognuno sta al suo posto certo ci sono dei compiti più prestigiosi
pagati meglio altri più duri ma dovete sopportare perché se ognuno sopporta e fa il suo lavoro il
mondo andrà avanti come vuole dio e chi è quali sono le condizioni e quali sono i lavori è ci
sono quelli che devono pregare pregare è fondamentale siamo tutti cristiani la salvezza è uno scopo
centrale della nostra vita quindi ci sono quelli che pregano i sacerdoti i monaci frati loro hanno
il compito più importante è per questo che gli pagate le decime e così via e li mantenete da
signori poi ci sono i nobili e i nobili comandano dirigono e difendono il paese perché i nobili
sono i cavalieri sono quelli che hanno le armi i cavalli che sanno usarle quando si fa la guerra
sono loro che vanno e loro difendono il paese e poi ci sono quelli che lavorano e lo sappiamo che
più dura è ma avrete la vostra ricompensa in paradiso lavorate rispettate i vostri signori
rispettate i vostri parroci e tutto andrà bene si sono sentiti dire questo per tutta la vita
ma perché in quell'estate del 1358 i contadini francesi invece han deciso che non è vero i
nobili non stanno rispettando il contratto non stanno facendo la loro parte li manteniamo a ufo
anzi peggio hanno tradito i loro obbligi allora lo sapete cosa sta succedendo in Francia nel
1358 siamo nel pieno della guerra dei cent'anni questa guerra che non finisce tapei con gli inglesi
che hanno invaso la Francia e ne hanno conquistato gran parte e i francesi sotto pressione che non riescono a
resistere meno di due anni prima 1356 a poitier la cavalleria francese ha perso una grande disastrosa
mente una grande battaglia il re di Francia Giovanni il buono di fidate dei rei che passano alla
storia come il buono in genere è l'unica qualità che si riesce a riconosce il re di Francia
Giovanni il buono è stato catturato dal nemico da un anno e mezzo e prigioniero a Londra e prigioniero
a Londra perché si sta negoziando il suo riscatto perché nelle guerre fra cavalieri c'è questa
piacevole usanza che tu in linea di massima il nemico se puoi evitare non è che lo ammazzi
poi si muore come mosca e lo stesso ma l'idea di fondo è se riesco a catturarlo il nobile nemico e me lo
porto a casa e poi si comincia a ragionare come ti chiami quanti castelli possiedi quanto paga
la tua famiglia questa è la consuetudina assolutamente universale rispettata seguita da
tutti normalissima ovviamente perché uno perché fa la guerra per divertirsi ma poi soprattutto
per arricchirsi e quindi uno fa la guerra così come gioca da zardo se mi va male va male ma se va
bene divento ricco quindi è consuetudina normale della cavalleria far pagare il riscato
all nemico catturato qui voi capite abbiamo catturato il re e adesso vediamo quanto pagherà
il regno di francia per la cronaca alla fine il regno di francia pagherà un riscato di 3 milioni
di scudi d'oro a occhio e croce qualche miliardo di euro in un regno ovviamente molto più povero
di quello che può essere un paese di oggi e pagheranno i contadini e tutti quanti naturalmente
non ci siamo ancora ma il re non c'è il re e prigioniero a l'ondra la francia è senza re c'è
un giovane principi per gente il delfino che nessuno sa se valga qualcosa il re non c'è la
guerra è persa e non è finita però c'è la tregua mentre si negozi il riscato tregua ma queste
sono guerre combattute da mercenari i quali se non li paghi e devono mantenersi lo stesso e quindi
anziché saccheggiare sotto comando saccheggiano in proprio il paese continua essere battuto
dai mercenari e i nobili non sono capaci di proteggere i loro contadini i nobili l'hanno
fatto vedere a Poitier che cosa valgono niente li abbiamo mantenuti tutta la vita nell'usso per
difendere il regno e loro sono stati sbaragliati hanno lasciato che il nostro re venisse catturato
dal demico e noi dovremmo continuare a mantenerli ma li ammazziamo tutti e però c'è anche un altro
dettaglio perché la situazione è complicata e vedete abbiamo siamo partiti dal dire i contadini
si arrabbiano contro i signori ma la politica è una cosa complessa anche allora vi dicevo prima che
c'è un giovane reggente e questo giovane reggente carlo il delfino si era rifugiato a parigi che è
l'unica grande città del regno parigi è una vera grande città a piena di mercanti di artigiani
dove girano un sacco di soldi ed è un comune organizzato chiaro non è come i comuni italiani che
non ubbidiscono a nessuno parigi obbedisci al re ma adesso che il re prigioniero e che il regno è
governato da un giovane e debole reggente i mercanti di parigi si dicono è forse potrebbe
essere l'occasione buona in cui parigi può cominciare a contare qualcosa il reggente ce
lo teniamo a parigi e il diciamo così il sindaco di parigi etienne marcell tecnicamente è il
prevosto dei mercanti comincia a spiegare al giovane reggente che adesso sono quelli di parigi
che gli dicono come deve gestire il regno peccato che il giovane reggente scappa da parigi e comincia
ad unare truppe per riprendersela con la forza quindi parigi è in stato di ribellione e di assedio
e il reggente ha dato ordine a tutti i nobili che hanno i castelli in tutta la giovane intorno a
parigi di mettere guarnigioni nei loro castelli per bloccare le strade impedire che parigi riceva
i fornimenti mettere guarnigioni nei castelli attenzione noi oggi andiamo a visitare un castello
del trecento che ne so finis in vale da osta e ce lo immaginiamo pieno di armigeri nemmeno per
idea gli armigeri costano normalmente si abita il padrone la moglie qualche domestico basta ma
quando c'è minaccia di guerra tocca fare questa cosa che li riempia tutti i ripugnanzi di sgusto
tirano fuori dei soldi e assumere qualche soldato per farla guardia sugli spalti bisogna farlo
il reggente ha chiesto ai nobili di fortificare i loro castelli i nobili allargano le braccia e si
rassegnano quindi quindi ci vogliono soldi per reclutare dei soldati e viveri riempire questi
castelli di viveri per mantenere queste guarnigioni chi paga i nostri contadini di conseguenza quello
che ci rivela un cronista è l'unico che ha fatto questo collega invece proprio in quel momento in
tutta quella zona i nobili avevano cominciato a dire i contadini pagate fuori i soldi fuori
vive di requisizioni con fische tasse perché dobbiamo fortificare i castelli e lì dice quel
cronista che i contadini hanno fatto due più due e dissero che i cavalieri che dovevano difenderli
avevano deciso di impadronirsi di tutti i loro beni quindi è lì che traboccano il vaso non
ne possiamo più qualche cronista si dice ma sono i parigini che li hanno sobillati perché
c'è sempre naturalmente questa idea quegli ignoranti dei contadini da soli cosa vuoi che
facciamo due più invece gli astutti parigini probabilmente li hanno sobillati ora non sembra
che i parigini li abbiano proprio sobillati ma di sicuro quando si è sparsa la voce di quello che
succedeva nelle campagne a parigi si sono fregati le mani quando il prevosto dei mercanti e quelli
del suo partito seppero queste notizie fecero finta di essere corrucciati ma mai nessuno che
andasse lì fu rimproverato o punito da loro in altre parole i ribelli vanno e vengono liberamente
con parigi e nessuno gli dice niente anzi i parigini già che ci sono escono in armi e vanno
a prendere i castelli intorno a parigi per evitare che il reggente li usi contro di loro questo fatto
di essere sospettati di complicità con i contadini a quelli di parigi piace poco specialmente
quando i contadini saranno stati sconfitti allora a quel punto etienne marcell scriverà una lettera
agli altri comuni di francia per dire che non è vero che loro a parigi hanno aiutato i ribelli
assolutamente no è vero che gli hanno mandato della gente dice etienne ma non le abbiamo mandati
per aiutarli li abbiamo mandati per cercare di frenarli un po per ridurre i loro eccessi dice
noi li abbiamo scritto di non uccidere le mogli e i figli dei gentiluomini a meno che non fossero
nemici della città di parigi in quel caso anche le moglie e i figli va bene insomma complicità di
sicuro anche se non li hanno forse sobillati e dunque e dunque questa marea di contadini non
si sta muovendo nel nulla in un tempo questo è il punto importante capite non è un tempo sempre
uguale te no no è quel momento lì e la congiuntura e cosa è successo l'anno scorso cosa sta
succedendo adesso la gente lo sai è quello che fa muovere la gente dopo di che è arrivati a
questo punto anche perché il mio tempo sta per scadere a questo punto in realtà comincia anche
il riflusso di questa rivolta ancora per un pochettino mi sono avvet cominciai il riflusso
hanno attraversato mezza francia saccheggiando castelli e case signorili e uccidendo i gentiluomini
che ricevano a mettere le mani loro le mogli i bambini i nobili scappavano dappertutto cavalieri
ed amme scudierie d'amigelle fugevano fu givano ovunque dove potevano con i bambini in collo
qualcuno in camicia un gran numero di loro si rifugiano in una cittadina vicino a parigi che
si chiama mo me auks a mo c'è un mercato in un'ansa della marna quasi completamente circondato
dal fiume murato una piccola fortezza lì sono affluiti centinaia di nobili con le loro moglie
e le loro figlie i bambini tutta questa gente è lì terrorizzata sono chiusi lì dentro vedono
il fumo dei loro castelli che bruciano lontano nella campagna non sanno cosa fare ci sono centinaia
di nobili e maschi uomini darme ma sono talmente terrorizzati che non sanno cosa fare quando a
parigi si viene a sapere che lì a mo che è a mezza giornata da parigi a piedi vicinissimo ci
sono tutti quei nobili da parigi esce una massa di sanculotti di ci verrebbe da dire se fossimo
nel 1789 una massa di popolani di parigi armati per andare a farla finita con tutti questi nobili
che stanno lì a mo i parigini arrivano a mo dove il sindaco di mo aveva giurato ai nobili di
proteggerli ma arrivando la folla dei parigini il sindaco di mogli fa aprire le porte della città
la pagherà poi cara e fecero mettere per le strade tavoli e tovaglie e sopra pane vino e carne
c'è sempre questa cosa ricorrente questi vanno poi devono mangiare però c'è un dettaglio che
vi ho letto e non avrete fatto caso lo sottolineo perché il medioevo è una strana mondo tovaglie
nel medioevo nessuno era così miserabile da non mettere una tovaglia sul tavolo l'idea di
mangiare su un tavolo di legno senza metterci una tovaglia non sarebbe venuta in mente assolutamente
a nessuno sarebbe stata la peggior rozezza e volgarità così per cui i ribelli che arrivano a mo
trovano i tavoli con le tovaglie ora a mo è appena arrivato un soccorso inaspettato qui partiamo
per paesi lontari voi mi scuserete ma è un mondo complesso questo lo vedete sono appena arrivati a
mo un gruppo di cavalieri capeggiati da due grossi nobili della francia del sud che si chiamano il
conte di fuo e il capital debuc il conte di fuo e il capital debuc sono un grosso personaggio del
partito francese e un grosso personaggio del partito inglese quando c'è la guerra si scannano però
sono parenti amici in questo momento c'è la tregua sono andati insieme in vacanza sul baltico
cosa vuol dire che sono andati in vacanza sul baltico in prussia vacanza e pelle
grinaggio anche ci si salva anche l'anime bellissimo in prussia ci sono i cavalieri teutonici i
quali fanno la guerra contro queste sciagurate tribu pagane i pruteni lituani eccetera tutta
europea sa che in quella lontana frontiera del mondo civile i prodi cavalieri teutonici cercano a
modo loro di cristianizzare i barbari pagani e vuoi non andare a dargli una mano è certo che ci
vai quando un nobile è disoccupato tempo di tregua nella guerra dei cent'anni per fortuna poi
ricomincia darà lavoro a lungo ma adesso siamo in tregua quindi cosa potremmo fare di divertente
facciamo un pelle grinaggio in prussia quando tu arrivi la i cavalieri teutonici ti accolgono
braccia aperte ti fermi qualche mese fai un po la guerra con loro scanni qualche pagano ti pagano
bene mangi bevi ti salvi l'anima vai al pelle grinaggio da maria di c'è in stoccova e poi torni a
casa felice e contento il conto di fuori il capital debuc con qualche decina di uomini d'arme sono
tornati dalla prussia arrivano in francia e gli dicono non sapete cosa sta succedendo in francia
i contadini si sono ribellati i nobili sono tutti fuggiti a ora sono fuggiti ci sono un sacco
di damigelle in pericolo nel mercato di mo che pici che sei tornato dalla prussia sei lì allenato
in forma cosa c'è di meglio damigelle in pericolo andiamo a salvarle e quindi il conto di fuori
il capital debuc sono arrivati i due buoni cavalieri si accordarono di andare a vedere le
dame e confortarle per quanto potevano poi non si sta mai con la ci scappa no tante donne e quindi sono
arrivati lì con una quarantina di uomini d'arme e sono entrati nel mercato i parigini non lo sanno
i parigini dopo aver mangiato e bevuto si presentano tracotanti alla porta del mercato di mo dicendo
adesso sfondiamo e ammazziamo tutti le porte si aprono ed escono tutti questi cavalieri in
armatura ben schierati dice un cronista a quel punto i parigini non ebbero più tutta quella
voglia di andare avanti che avevano prima ma i cavaliere a questo punto attaccano e qui c'è uno
dei passi più straordinari dal punto di vista proprio dell'idea del cronista che il mondo è fatto
di due razze diverse cioè i nobili e i villani sono due razze diverse si misero davanti a questi
villani neri e piccoli e male armati con la bandiera del conte di fuà e il pennone del capital
e lancia impugno e caricano e i parigini si disperdono e vengono inseguiti e fatti a pezzi e li
ammazzarono come bestie e ne uccisero tanti che erano tutti stracchi e sporchi cioè non c'era
fai più dalla stanchezza forza di ammazzarne e li gettavano a mucchi nel fiume marna e li uccidevano
come maiali gli uni sugli altri le vie erano così strette che non si passava e poi a questo punto
messi in rotta i parigini a questo punto i nobili dicono dove il sindaco dimò che li ha fatti entrare
e i villani della città che si erano ecco e a questo punto danno fuoco alla città e la bruciarono
tutta con tutti i villani del borgo che riuscirono a chiudere dentro il sindaco è arrestato messo a
morte atto finale entra in cena di 9 personaggi tardissimo 10 minuti al massimo finiamo atto
finale gli giac che hanno capito che i nobili stanno cominciando a reagire si sono nominati un capo
un capo perché per combattere bisogna avere qualcuno che ti dà un minimo di ordine dice un cronista
un contadino più furbo degli altri che si chiamava guion cal sarebbe charl ma nel dialetto della
francia del nord all'epoca la pronuncia era cal questo guion cal è un uomo che se ne intendeva
che sapeva parlare bene è di bel aspetto e gli giac ne fecero il loro capo ma lui vedeva bene che
era gente che non avrebbe combinato gran che e rifiutò di comandarli ma gli giac lo presero e
ne fecero il loro capo insieme con un uomo che era ospedaliere cioè frate dell'ordine di san giovanni
ordine militare e aveva visto la guerra e anche gion cal aveva vista in altre parole qui adesso
subentra un aspetto fondamentale questa massa di contadini armati alla me bella e meglio ma sono
tanti fanno tanta paura ma se si trovano in campo aperto davanti a dei nobili non hanno speranza
perché i nobili sanno fare la guerra i contadini no e saperla fare vuol dire saperla fare sapere come
devi metterdi qual è il momento giusto averlo ecco i contadini non ce l'hanno tanto che gion cal
e qui si cercano due che almeno la guerra ogni tanto l'hanno vista l'hanno fatta e li costringono
a comandarli e l'altro personaggio che entra in scena è un po il contraltare del re di francia
giovanni il buono che se ne sta prigioniero nella torre di londra questo è il re di navarra la navarra
è un piccolo regno indipendente sui pirenei più tardi sarà annesso alla francia se voi ricordate
dal tempo dei tre moschettieri in poi il re di francia si chiama re di francia e di navarra
all'epoca è un piccolo regno indipendente e il re di navarra ha il piacevole soprannome di carlo
il malvagio carlo il malvagio re di navarra è cugino del re di francia ed è convinto che il
regno di francia toccherebbe a lui per cui è tutta la vita che intriga per diventare re di francia
si è messo d'accordo con quelli di parigi era parigi d'accordo con etienne marcell per farsi
sponsorizzare come futuro re di francia anche gli inglesi lo appoggiano e i cronisti a questo
punto a sorpresa ci dicono e gli giac pensavano di essere appoggiati da lui gli giac pensavano di
trovare un alleato dicono alcuni che gli giac si aspettavano che il re di navarra dovesse aiutarli
per l'alleanza che aveva col prevosto dei mercanti ma allora capite come dalla rivolta senza capi
così insensata che abbiamo visto all'inizio che roba che viene fuori viene fuori un mondo dove
si sa certo c'è parigi e c'è il re di navarra e il nostro re è là e questa e c'è la politica
sostanzialmente ci sono delle prospettive gli giac pensano che il re di navarra potrebbe
essere la loro carta vincente ma anche i nobili lo pensano e i nobili vanno da carlo il malvagio
e gli dicono siri voi siete l'uomo più nobile del mondo non potete lasciare che la nobilità
sia nientata se questa gente che si dicono gli giac dura a lungo e se i comuni cittadini li
sostengono abbatteranno la nobilità e il re di navarra decide che è vero che tocca a lui risollevare
le sorti della nobilità di francia e marcia contro gli giac e li trova perché quando ci è saputo
che arrivava ghiom call ha detto agli giac che non era il caso di stare a aspettarlo e che era molto
meglio andarsene tutti a chiudersi dentro parigi ma gli giac rifiutano avevano troppa fiducia in
se stessi perché si vedevano in gran numero a questo punto sono costretti a combattere e
ghiom call e l'ospedaliere cercano almeno di schierarli con un po di ordine in reparti separati
come si faceva nel medioevo perché quando un reparto va dentro e poi fra un'ora saranno
senza fiato e allora dobbiamo avere un altro reparto fresco dietro sono proprio le cose elementari
no dell'arte della guerra quelle cose che non sanno quelli che poi fanno i film tipo il signore
degli anelli dove vedi l'esercito tutti che corrono insieme ecco non è così alcuni corno
altri aspettano e poi li fanno schierare fanno trovano un fossato ci mettiamo dietro il fossato
ed avanti carri carretti tiriamo giù le porte dalle case del villaggio ci fortifichiamo solo così
abbiamo qualche speranza e fanno un altro reparto in retroguardia a cavallo 600 uomini a cavallo
la maggior parte in armatura ma allora non sono tutti i contadini allora c'è anche della gente
per bene che si è munita loro diventa sempre più complicato il reddina varra arriva gli giac sono
gli schierati da due giorni ad aspettarlo e si tenevano informazione con faccia spavalda e
suonavano corni e trombe e gli giac e gridavano a gran voce monjuà e portavano molte insegne di
pinte a fior d'alisi fior d'alisi e l'insegna del regno di francia avere quelle insegne vuol dire
mi ripeto e scusatemi noi siamo il regno di francia monjuà monjuà è l'antico grido di guerra
dei re di francia fin dalle chanson de gest carlo manio e così via loro stanno dicendo il
re non c'è e prigioniero noi siamo il regno di francia dopo di che il reddina varra non per niente
si chiama carlo il malvagio perché gli manda a dire che vorrebbe fare una tregua perché lui è
interessato a stare dalla loro parte e vorrebbe parlare col capo e gion calpo vero e avrà pensato
che forse di un re ci si può fidare ci va dice il cronista semplicemente senza neanche chiedere
degli ostaggi per garantire gli oncal ci va dal reddina varra e tutti gli giac sono lì che si
fregano le mani dicendo il reddina varra sta da nostra parte e di colpo il reddina varra li
fatta a care dai suoi uomini darmi inglesi e francesi e gli giac sono messi in rotta quelli a
cavallo si salvano la grande massa che sono a piedi vengono sterminati dopo di che il reddina
varra fa decapitare gli omcal e sarebbe finita ma non è finita anche se è finita davvero
è cinque minuti perché i nobili si vogliono vendicare avete fatto la vostra parte adesso tocca
a noi e i nobili fanno venire altri nobili d'altre regioni si armano e cominciano a dare la caccia ai
contadini attaccarono questa mala gente da tutte le parti e li uccidevano e li impiccavano i primi
alberi che trovavano gli uomini darmi andarono di villaggio in villaggio bruciarono e saccheggiarono
tutti tutto agli uni come agli altri perché non avevano tempo di fare un inchiesta in altre parole
dovunque i contadini si sono ribellati adesso è ammazzali tutti ci saranno i colpevole gli
innocenti non importa non abbiamo tempo il sirio di qc attaccò i contadini e li distrusse ne
impiccò e fece morire di mala morte così tanti che non è da credere a raccontarlo ne bruciarono
in una chiesa ben trecento il conte di rusili fece impiccare le loro porte e il paese fu bruciato
in molti luoghi e il popolo ucciso è inseguito e le loro ricchezze prese che erano molte di nuovo
questi contadini ribelli non sono dei disperati che muoio di fame è un mondo contadino aggiatto che
non ne può più di pagare le tasse ma adesso i nobili saccheggiano rubano si impadroniscono di
tutto a parigi il prevosto dei mercanti etienne marcell scrive una bella lettera a tutti i comuni
di francia dicendo eh ma adesso stanno esagerando la repressione e scappate di mano ma anche etienne
marcell ha perso la sua occasione il popolo di parigi e volubile e vedendo che le cose si mettono
male passa dall'altra parte per cui pochi giorni dopo il 21 luglio 58 etienne marcell viene ammazzato
dagli stessi parigini che lo avevano eletto e si dà la caccia ai contadini per giorni si bruciano
villaggi si porta via la loro roba finalmente quando i nobili ne hanno abbastanza se ne tornano a
casa e la giacheria è finita rimangono poche pendenze il re giovanni verrà liberato tra due anni
resterà ancora due anni prigioniero a Londra poi verrà liberato il compromessa di pagare il riscatto
e lasciando due dei suoi figli in ostaggio in inghilterra poi siccome il riscato tarda a
raccogliersi uno dei due figli del re scappa dall inghilterra se ne torna in francia a questo punto
il re giovanni il buono avendo dato la sua parola d'onore torna volontariamente in inghilterra a
darsi prigioniero e morirà lì mentre nel suo regno si raccolgono gli se non ho contato male
11.000 kilogrammi d'oro del riscatto carlo il malvagio re di navarra vivere ancora 30 anni facendo
tutte le guerre possibili e non riuscirà mai a realizzare il suo sogno di diventare il re di
francia il reggente carlo che noi abbiamo appena nominato e che sembrava un burattino un ragazzino
diventerà il buon re carlo quinto carlo quinto il saggio uno dei migliori re di francia della
storia e riconquisterà agli inglesi quasi tutta la francia i contadini francesi e il popolo di
parigi continueranno a ribellarsi un'infinità di volte ogni volta inventandosi dei nomi strani per
la propria ribellione la rivolta dei tuchini la rivolta dei martelli le ogni volta repressi fino a
quella volta ci vorrà un sacco di tempo naturalmente ecco fino a quella volta nel 1789 quando i
protagonisti saranno di nuovo re di francia i nobili i contadini il popolo di parigi e quella
volta le cose andranno un po diversamente grazie